good morning everyone welcome to this
extraordinary meeting of cabinet
do we have any apologies for absent sam
we do we have apologies from councillor
parry and councillor pemberton from
little late thank you and
disclosures of interest any disclosures
of interest
i'll take that as a resounding no
so
future relationship with warwick
district council and future working
arrangements
this stems from
the meeting
where
david buckland and i were present with
uh councillor andrew dave from warwick
district council
and chris elliott
chief executive of warwick district
council
and at that meeting
basically the merger came to an end
i requested
[Music]
to send a letter to the secretary of
state michael gove
requesting a delay in any decision until
we'd had the opportunity to get the due
diligence reports
one on both councils and one on
wilberton homes
and had time to study them and
understand the implications
our understanding was
that
the decision would be made towards the
end of may
we
had
from warwick district council
notification
that
uh board approval by milverton homes
will be required for non-disclosure
agreement and that board meeting
wouldn't happen
until the 27th of may
in other words the secretary of state
could have made a decision before we'd
had
enough information to inform what we did
so
uh
the reality actually is that at the end
of that meeting for all practical
purposes
uh the merger was off
so this paper
actually formalizes the implications of
that
first thing it does is it says that
we will make a formal submission to the
to the department for leveling up
housing and communities
withdrawing
that submission
work on full service integration of
teams across stratford on avenue warwick
district councils is terminated
and work on identification of sharing
civic and office accommodation is also
terminated then we removed from the
constitution
all the committees and groups that were
formed jointly
so that is namely the joint appointment
steering group the joint appointment
subcommittee and the joint arrangement
steering group and transfer terms of
reference from both committees back to
employment committee
so the reality is we're unwinding all
the joint arrangements that were put in
place
arrangements for the joint management
team terminated from the 12th of may
and interim management team structure
for stratford district council be noted
and then we've got changes to the
officer scheme of delegation as a
consequence of the transfer of service
function show
and
there is in the in
one further thing in terms of
just
sorry mr grafton
so so there's a pink sheet in front of
you members which just makes some
amendments to appendix four appendix 4
to the report is the one that is
suggesting changes to the officer scheme
of delegation and the pink paper before
you've just got a couple of
additional amendments one in relation to
bridal ways and footpaths because the
because of the complications of the
process and the second one um in
relation to the public health control of
diseases act 1984 which is around public
burials um so those are just two slight
amendments for you to take into account
thank you chair
thank you mr grafton i think that is an
indication of the amount of detailed
work that actually needs doing to unwind
the detailed proposals in terms of the
joint working and proposed merger
and
the final two points are it's noted work
on the joint south warwickshire local
plan and joint south warwickshire
economic strategy will continue
and it's noted that existing
arrangements in relation to climate
change will continue those two points
are for noting
it is worth saying
that
we have
endeavoured to keep an awful lot
of the
joint working that is already set up in
place
uh so the reality actually is when we
look at the joint south quadrature local
plan there is an awful lot of work in
that
that continue in terms of the background
work
uh where sharing it
reduces costs
and actually is beneficial given we have
in effect
one
geographical
sorry one economic area
when it comes to the real detail on that
that may well be a different issue but
that is somewhere down the track
in terms of the joint south works or
economic strategy
that work is continuing because we are
really one economic unit
and it is very interesting that uh
i had a meeting with john carford
and andrew day yesterday it was actually
very cordial and very productive
councillor pemberton
thank you leader i just wanted to
comment that i am grateful for your
comments in relation to the
southwesterly local plan
as the portfolio holder for policy i
have already been approached by a number
of
uh town and parish councils
who
[Music]
how we've been hunted down councillor
kettle
thank you leader um a number of town and
parish councils who have
whilst understandable quite unfounded
fears about the future of the local plan
process so i'm i am heartened to hear
your statement that confirms my own that
there is no change as far as the plan is
concerned
the evidence base will be gathered on a
joint basis
the the the
the approach across the south
warwickshire area to leverage the
benefits of being able to discuss
at that scale with infrastructure
team two projection dear boy projection
um
and we will end up with uh a very
comprehensive plan that serves our
residents well so i am i am glad for
your uh putting that on the record
leader thank you
thank you councillor pemberton
i think if we actually look
at the
arrangements
uh for continuing work with warwick
district council
will continue with business rates
administration because they've been in
place for 15 years
we'll continue with information
governance because it actually makes
sense and it's worked effectively
we've recently agreed to appoint a joint
hs2 liaison officer and there is
absolutely no point in having two
when one can perfectly easily do the job
for both
legal services is a shared service which
went live on the first of april
and the joint arrangement is scheduled
to serve a collective 150 000 a year and
that is a service that under
mr grafton's leadership will be
providing a service to both councils
uh development of south warwick's your
local plan and south forex or economic
development strategy
uh
both myself
and councillor pemberton have already uh
commented on
uh in terms of joint waste and recycling
there is a contract
the contract was signed
last year and will
this year and it's initially for an
eight year period
uh
this contract will continue because
obviously it is a contract
there is one point of contact and that
will be
uh
sdc will lead on the contract management
and the mobilization of the new contract
and will recover costs at the relevant
proportion from warwick district
the sdc contact centre will continue to
support
warwick district council in respect of
charges for the green west subscriptions
and any telephone inquiries in relation
to new wasted recycling contract
the picture i'm painting is that an
awful lot of the things that were
actually set in place
up to the termination of the merger will
continue because it actually makes sense
to do it
and
i have to say that the officers have
done great work
in actually sorting those things out in
time for this meeting
uh the other thing that i would say is
oh no sorry there are several other
things
yes
sorry mr brooklyn just passed me now
telling me what i need to say
but
but he does that very frequently uh
the working together program team uh
that was set up to actually help bring
the merger about
obviously is no longer required
and i have to say and this is a note
that mr brooklyn passed me but i would
absolutely endorse what he says
the
work that they did was really excellent
in terms of all the background work in
terms of helping to pull it together
and
the people in that team i think
demonstrated
clearly
just how competent and capable they are
counselor junit i believe you want to
come in at this point it's just that the
overview and scrutiny committee
particularly um that that team was
particularly addressed and our grateful
thanks were uh we thanked all officers
but we said that that particular team
needed to have uh
them told that obvious company did uh
appreciate their services
thank you councillor junior councillor
pemberton
thank you i think every single one of us
appreciates the skill diligence and
success of that team
and
i i assume i'm pushing at an open door
here but it would seem that at an
organisational level
it would
it would be somewhat of an own goal to
lose that resource as we move into a
position where we have to reconfigure
ourselves as an organization going
forward
so whilst uh clearly cannot seek
confirmation of posts in this meeting uh
just putting a marker down that uh
certainly i i'm of the view that the
skills and talent should be retained to
give us the very best possible
opportunity uh and for them to be
redeployed in a way that enables this
organization to move forward positively
in a post-merger world
i think your comments are exceedingly
well made councillor pemberton and i
would wholly agree with them
um
councillor cargill
yes just to reiterate that point i've
worked worked with the uh that team for
the last 18 months two years best part
of um under my portfolio and i must
admit they have been
excellent they've been
very collaborative working together
um engaging with all the officers across
the districts it's been an experience
and i'm one that we do not want to lose
that
that skill and that knowledge so yes i
just confirmed what uh council pemberton
has said
i i think there is a very interesting
general point here
uh
going forward despite the fact that uh
the merger will not continue uh
challenges remain
and we really need we'll need all the
skills capability and competence we've
got
to actually meet those challenges
head-on
just con sorry counselor harvey
it would be invidious i think not to
mention staff in general uh of the
authority because it has been a period
of uncertainty and strain stress
i'm sure there have been a few tears as
well as cheers uh over the past few
months so i think it would be helpful if
if
staff in general knew
how sensitive cabinet members feel to
the circumstances they've had to
go through over the past few months and
to receive our our thanks for their
patience and their efforts
thank you councillor harvey points
extremely well made
uh there is absolutely no doubt about it
that the last few months
uh
as we attempted to put the merger
together have been uh remarkably
stressful for an awful lot of people
it certainly created an awful lot of
uncertainty
um
i think at the end of the day we have
taken the right decision
in terms of terminating the merger
and basically a part of this paper is
how we now lay the foundations for
moving forward
and
just to continue
uh with some of the benefits or that are
arising
from the merger process despite the fact
it's over in terms of
cctv
we are going to be reliant on warwick
for supervision
because we are facing difficulties in
recruiting someone to fill that role
uh and one of the really key points is
about finances and budgets
and the reality actually is
that
all the things we continue doing jointly
actually do
result in
positive
results
for
the council
uh that the expenditure total
applicable to stratford
was 162 and a half thousand
uh the
ongoing savings we get from that
are 271 000
in other words there's pretty much a net
benefit to us of 110 000
from all the joint work that is going on
that does not include
some of the one-off savings that may
well be made
and although these are estimated
that would be a total of another 570
000
and it does
demonstrate
the benefits that we have achieved from
going through the process
despite the fact that we have now
withdrawn it there is also at this point
in time absolutely no need for an
emergency budget
uh
that does not mean to say that when we
get to the
uh
financial settlement from government at
the end of this year
that there may not be the need for some
further
quite tough decisions depending on
their
generosity or otherwise of that
settlement
so internal nordic services we will
uh
go back to having the services delivered
by warwickshire county council
and at this point i would just reiterate
that there has been an awful lot of work
done by the senior team here
in terms of
both unwinding some of the aspects of
the proposed merger and actually
continuing with others and this work has
being done in a relatively short time
scale
so basically i think
that summarizes the paper
and
essentially we now have to say do we
accept the recommendations
on
page
one
council unit
i wonder whether at this point it'd be
worth me um reporting what came from the
ovum scrutiny committee uh yesterday or
is that suitable timing no i think it
would attorney will be spot on okay um
the uh the chair of ovue and scrutiny he
sent me um a summary
and
of the of the discussions and i i will
add a couple of extra things to that to
that
there was a request to change the
wording from councillor curtis around
recommendations seven and eight
due to these being notes rather than
votes and so the insertion of in
addition it is also noted that is
advised
um but
in general the overview and scrutiny
committee carried out a detailed
scrutiny of the paper and the background
which led to the report in particular we
went back through
all the um
the papers that originally came to the
cabinet and council in 9th of december
2021 and even before that we went to
through to the uh lga financial review
that was done in may 2021
um we requested as a committee a task
and finished group comprising of warwick
district council and stratfor district
councillors to commence once the
recommendations from the previous merger
attempt with stratfor district council
and churwal are noted
and ideas formed around the parameters
of such a task and finished group around
the lessons learned to prevent us from
finding ourselves in such a position
again
and it was at the discussion at the
opium scrutiny there was particular
concern
that looked looked at back at the lga
report
to note that there were some
recommendations in there that we might
want to re-look at as part of that task
and finish group
not only about the um the the finances
and the loan for the local housing
company but also whether or not there
were were uh sufficient um effort but a
sufficient um recommendation
recommendation to the
paid to the shadow merge savings plan
report um that the lga asked for and the
lga also mentioned in their report about
political management and uh it
recommended that um when the final
review is done
we should look out whether or not there
was a sufficiently clear well thought
out program of work with rational and
granular savings targets and whether or
not or not there was a ruthless focus on
financial benefit delivery and whether
there should be uh where the risk the
risk of distraction uh was considered
those were in the regional report and at
the overview and scrutiny committee
recommended that we should revisit those
particular parts of that report as well
as uh talking to warwick district
councillors about their input thank you
councillor pemberton and then councillor
bark
thank you leader um
absolutely first of all a clarification
piece i didn't quite follow
the proposed amendment by councillor
curtis i didn't quite understand what
was being said there apologies i've got
i've got my sleepy head on
this that was the first part
about so on page one of the cabinet
agenda you've got recommendations to
council you've got eight recommendations
yeah what i understand is the
recommendation from the audience
over the scrutiny committee is just
before recommendations seven and eight
in addition because
these aren't decisions but it wasn't
politic it was really
a decision between the two authorities
is a positive statement that we wanted
to capture what will continue to work
but as a subheading before
recommendation seven saying in addition
it is also noted that
and then number seven
so
just coming to the substantive bit um
it's right and proper that
organizationally
we should take a deep dive
uh to understand and to learn any
lessons around
uh the process that we as an
organization have gone through over the
last 18 months or so i suppose the only
questions for me are are practical ones
um
you taught in terms of uh
a task and finished group
and you talked in terms also of warwick
members
and in real terms it takes two to tango
so i think
the only thing the thing that crops up
to my mind is
well a is task and finish group
the most appropriate vehicle for it or
is it more a sort of select committee
type approach where there's questioning
if you will
and b
um
if
we cannot secure
uh the
uh
the involvement of warwick and members
of warwick
how do we approach it then because
almost by definition then
the the rounded picture that you are
seeking as an overview and scrutiny
committee
is not going to be really available to
you because you're only going to have
the one half if you will and if that is
the case then you're going to have to
frame your understanding in your
reference
around that and to accept
that it's a partial piece of work and
founded on lessons only that we can
learn and there will be some limitations
to that because you don't have the full
360 by having everybody and i i'm not i
personally i'm comfortable with
uh there being such a process i think
there is a question to go back to
for overview and scrutiny committee to
consider about and perhaps in
conjunction with the chief executive
um
about the best way of doing it and what
the limitations might be and i make that
as an observation and in no way am i
seeking to sort of stymie because i'm
absolutely certain we should do this
piece of work and quickly
i do think a task and finish group of
the osc would be the best way to to
approach this review is it's exactly the
same approach that we took when the
chair was south offense worked working
i do take your point though we would
could request
that white district councillors are
involved we can't compel them to
participate so if that's recommendation
from the group we will endeavor
um thank you
these are very loud today aren't they
making my ears ache
um
i'm perfectly content about having a
task and finish group and as the chief
executive says that's the most sensible
way to approach it
i really don't want it to be to be a
process that goes on and on and on is a
continuous
scab-picking exercise i note that uh the
mention of the relationship with
cherwell and i would point out that one
of the things learned from the
relationship with cherwell was that in
attempting a merger with warwick
we were going for full political merger
because we realized that the shared
services didn't work so i think that big
lesson
was learnt so it's obviously extremely
valuable to do that what i also don't
want to see
and i hope you'll bear with me on this
one because i'm always saying it about
staff i don't want to see
our staff spread too thin in doing this
exercise so it will be so the exercise
will be done by
presumably those of us who've been
involved and you will question those of
us who've been involved
um
and and staff and that's where you will
come to the conclusion because we've got
quite a lot to do to get the
wheels under what we need to do now
i think you're absolutely right council
mark come to the kettle
right it's working man
um
i think we we must remember absolutely
right we should have review of what went
on
um and make sure we did you know we
learned lessons from that process but i
think we have to remember the
fundamental issue
uh as set out by the lj was required or
put a
suggestion this council should
investigate
um the 100 percent
holy and subsidiary of work district
council
um
the timetable of which
uh warwick were unable to allow us to
commence that until effectively the
secretary of state had confirmed the
merger
um
that they were not prepared to allow us
to look at that the 100
subsidiary before
the merger would effectively have been
set in concrete
um
was the biggest issue that stopped as
far as i'm concerned
my
my comfort with the merge going ahead i
think we all in this room recognized the
huge strategic benefits of the two
authorities merging together
and that logic is the same today as it
was on the 12th of
december before we took the
uh
decision to formally merge
but it would have been
um
i would almost go to save unprofessional
for this authority to go into a merger
having not been able to carry out
a due diligence exercise that had been
recommended by the lga
um and the whole purpose of the
duologist's exercise is to make sure
that we have a full understanding
before we go into merger of what we're
taking on
rather
um we got to remember that fundamental
issue that was not our decision our
decision was to merge
but having carried out due diligence it
was not our decision to prevent that
carrying out on a timely basis
thank you councillor kettle councillor
shenton
your mind's very uh
uh very quick
as far as i'm concerned um
the day the danger of raking over the
embers and the coals uh is that we stir
up um ill feeling if we start dragging
in or asking
warwick um to come in we already know a
lot of the reasons
why
this has failed and partly around the
lga report partly around trust
and the due diligence
i was not i think there are lessons
perhaps to be there
i think
i'm more in the the uh
the arena of we have to look forward
rather than backwards on this
thank you councillor shenton
um i think some very good points have
been made
i think it is one thing
to have
the huge benefit of 2020 hindsight
when you look at a report and you say
this
when you're actually going through the
process
then i think all of us have been heavily
involved in it realize that it becomes
very messy
it is not straightforward
not only that the further you go through
it the more you actually discover
and the more things change
and the reality actually is it is not a
linear simple process
it is very messy
uh an awful lot of things happen
and one of the key issues is around
trust
and if you look at the analysis of
mergers in the private sector
most of them fail
because of cultural differences
and you don't underst well personally
i don't think we fully understood how
different the cultures were between
warwick and stratford and you only begin
to find that out by trying to work
together
and i think it will be far too easy to
look back at reports and say we should
have done this we should have done that
when you're in the middle of a messy
process
that is not easy
and
i think it's unfortunate we've ended up
with the position we have but i think
the right decision was taken
and i think the position we're in now we
have gained benefits from it
we have learned lessons from it
and
the reality actually is we are now in a
very different position
and i believe i'm correct in saying that
this paper will be replicated
in warrick district council today yeah
but very similar they they have other
recommendations that they need to
consider in relation to their uh
statutory officer positions but
generally it's the same before
thank you mr brookland
sorry council jr
uh just just to rewind up because the uh
overview of scrutiny is overview as well
as scrutiny um so we
our task is to ask the right questions
uh in order that um
good policy can be made but it's also
our task to be involved in
the the pre-formation of policy uh and
going forward and part of that is also
to look at um where the council is given
that
a lot of the reasoning behind the merger
was to do with financial savings to go
forward and actually look at the
financial savings and whether or not um
we are going to be what kind of position
the council as a whole is going to be in
um so i i i would propose that um not
only uh from the the what uh the chair
paniano donald said about uh looking
backwards but maybe also as part of that
process would be involved before any
auto budget uh review is done uh that's
some of the difficulties of the council
in the finance is also run through that
uh opium scrutiny committee thank you
thank you councillor junior your points
are noted
so with that
sorry councillor harvey
um
i just want to make
the point that uh what
i'm perfectly
comfortable with a task and finish group
seeking to learn the lessons from from
the exercise that we've just been
through
and i hear what cancers units says about
concentrating on the financial
implications of the of the merger and
that's finding and dandy
my concern however is that one of the
thing one of the one of the big lessons
that we learned and it refers to the
question of culture
is that um in this council we have a a a
conservative group which has the
majority that enables the the council
and the cabinet to operate in a
particular way
the circumstances in warwick district
council are very different
and they do not have a majority uh up
for for one party or another and i think
one of the one of the lessons that i
think we've learned as a cabinet in
particular is the complexities and the
subtleties of having to operate uh in in
the circumstances where a party does not
have does not command a majority
that work district council are forced to
operate in probably a more difficult way
in a more challenging way than than we
do and
that for me has been a significant
learning lesson so i hope that the task
and finish group while it will no doubt
have a lot to delve into as far as
questions to do with finance are
concerned i hope that they
have a wider remit to learn lessons
so that we get a round picture of the
lessons learned to be learned from from
the from the the merger
thank you councillor harvey
i would absolutely endorse your point
about the complexities and subtleties
there is absolutely no doubt at all in
my mind
uh
that
these were fully exposed i think in the
budget process that warwick district
undertook
and really came to the fore
the one
thing i would say
is that
we
have i think
ended this merger
on
in a way that maintains good
relationships with warwick district
council and that is actually important
because we are still cooperating on
things
and it is really important
that we do not
uh undermine
positive working relationships
councillor kettle
um i was just going to say that whether
including the recommendations we should
recommend a vote of thanks to
the senior management team david
buckland and his his
colleagues for the enormous effort they
made i mean it it was on top of their
day job
and i just think we should recognize
that formally in our recommendation to
council to include a vote of thanks to
them for what they've achieved
i think uh it is a point exceedingly
well made councillor kettle because i
think we all saw firsthand
the amount of time the amount of effort
that was put in i think to be fair it's
not only by the senior management team
but it's by an awful lot of staff
and i think that they rose to the
challenges magnificently
and
i think it has been
an inspiration to all of us
and i think one of the things that
really has come out of the merging which
is hugely beneficial
is it cemented the very close and
productive working relationship
between in particular members of cabinet
and the senior team and that really is
important because if you want an
effective organization
those relationships really matter
so
i think
can we actually do that
yeah absolutely so in that kid
[Music]
i'm not sure mr grafton would agree with
that
good
so
in that case who would like to propose
that this afternoon counselor kettle
thank you
uh so with that the recommendations on
page one
um
sorry just just just you're going to
that kind of just um point out at um
recommendation
six
to add the words
after as shown in appendix four
and the amendments to appendix iv
that's okay thank you
the recommendations one to eight bearing
in mind the changes in wording to cover
points seven and eight would you have mr
brookland
so
as amended
so
are we happy with all those
recommendations to council members of
cabinet
thank you members of cabinet
uh
councillor cargill
thank you uh final point if i may
finally final point um
for the record and i it has to be for
the record this is my last cabinet i'm
stepping down today
um it's been a pleasure working my
colleagues on cabinet and along with the
senior management team especially and as
you said over this last period it has
cemented those working relationships
um i would say and you know i suppose
you should say you would say this but i
think that cabinets and officers have
worked in a highly professional manner
over this period
and we only see a small amount of the
work that goes into a paper that comes
out for cabinet and into
council
all the work is scrupulously
examined
along with the offices and some robust
discussions are had
and it ends up with what i believe to be
very well honed proposals
now i'm sure it will be a wrench for my
colleagues on council on cabinet for me
to go but i'm sure you'll muddle through
in the end
thank you for those kind words uh
counselor cargill
uh
yes
but
before we close the meeting mr grafton
is quite rightly pointing out to me that
we have an item for
uh
and i think in a way that demonstrates
the
strengths we have realized our
management team possesses
and i think that again has been a
welcome area of understanding so bearing
in mind mr grafton's pointing finger
is there any urgent business
no no
in that case
thank you members of cabinet and
officers meeting closed